The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today's
lecture is supposed
to be about navigation,
but in many ways,
that can be a
pretty dry subject.
So what I've done is I've made
it very graphical and sort
of active and animated.
No, this is just a folder.
This isn't the-- Anyway, so a
couple of administration pieces
is the Sprint
submission deadline.
The Sprint Tournament
will be held on Wednesday,
but you need to submit your
code by Monday at midnight.
There's a little
bit of wiggle room
where you can submit it like
a few hours after midnight,
but don't plan on that.
Yeah.
And you submit your code
to the Sprint Tournament
and that makes you
eligible to win prizes.
And it also helps you
with your seeding,
so that you'll be seeded into
a higher part of the tournament
bracket for the next tournament.
So yeah, you've got
to get started early.
We'll also be offering
another source of money
for you, as if you didn't
have enough sources of money
with the Sprint Tournament,
and all of those special prizes
we're giving out, and
the tournament itself.
We're also offering
an extra prize
for the team that is most
helpful to other teams
and people.
So that means that now
you have an incentive,
beyond just being a good
person, to help other teams out.
We'll have a survey that
goes out in the last week.
And so if you've
gangstered everybody
into voting you as
helpful, then you'll
win the prize without
being helpful.
So just keep that in mind.
All right.
So today we're supposed
to talk about navigation.
Let's have a look at this thing.
Here is a program that
I wrote that makes
a maze, piece by piece.
There's probably a
smarter way to do it,
but I just built
random walks that self
avoid onto one another
to make a maze.
And what I've done here is
I've got a variable called
delay that lets me change the
speed at which a computation is
performed.
So you can see here,
if I set it to 0.5,
then we'll be here all day,
because each one of these paths
is going to take a half
a second to put together.
But this is helpful, because a
lot of times a pathing routine
will happen instantly.
Or in compute time,
it'll happen fast,
and you won't really
notice what's going on.
So let's go ahead and set
this to a small number.
Now we've got a map that has a
bottom left and an upper right.
And we're going to use
this map to demonstrate
a bunch of pathing techniques.
So we're trying to get from the
bottom left to the upper right.
The first method we're going
to use is depth first search.
So I'm going to run this.
Oh, it finished.
That was dumb.
Let's make the delay 0.1.
Yeah.
So now, you can see I'm
starting from the left
and I'm going along in a
depth first search, which
means that I'm looking
toward the end first.
And then after I have
investigated everything,
I'll start again at
the next branch point.
So I haven't even
looked at this.
I've gone along and, yeah,
so I check that-- oh, done.
OK.
So now you can see it finished.
But I'm going to
run it once more,
and I want you to keep
your eye on the colors that
are displayed on the right here.
The color indicates how
far it thinks something is.
And it's scaled
from white to black.
So when it finds
something that's darker,
it will brighten
up this other area.
So pathing systems are
basically just a way
of trying all the
possible combinations.
But there are little tricks
of making that smarter.
I'll show it one last time.
The point is to make
it smarter than trying
every possible combination.
Like for example, if you've
visited an area before,
then don't try that again.
Or if you visited
an area before,
and you got there closer
than you currently are,
then don't try that again.
So there you have it.
There is an example
of depth first search.
And we're going to move on
and show an example of breadth
first search to show
how different it is.
They're going to look pretty
similar for this example,
but the next example I give
won't be pathing in a maze.
It'll be pathing in
something that's more open.
So here's a breadth
first search.
And you can see, it's sort
of parallel pursuing paths.
Like it's doing a little down
here and a little down there.
And it's jumping back
and forth between things
that have the same depth.
I'm going to show it again and
I want you to pay attention
to the colors, specifically
white and black.
You see that it never goes
back and updates a point
all at once.
It does it bit by bit.
So you see areas are gradually
lightening, rather than
lightening all at once.
So I show this one more time.
This is breadth first
search on this maze computed
in real time.
I can change this maze
and it'll come out again.
For the explicit purpose of
demonstrating the concept,
I actually had to go to the
trouble of writing a breadth
first search.
It's not that hard, at
least in Mathematica,
and I'm pretty sure it's
not hard in any language
to write something that works.
And we'll talk more
about that later.
But I know a lot
of you have already
heard of a lot of
concepts in navigation.
And you've also got Wikipedia.
You could just go online
and find, oh, I see.
These are the things that
are important for that.
So let's move on.
Now we have a bug navigation.
Bugs apparently find their
way round rooms and things
by walking until they hit
an object, like a wall,
and then they just
follow along the wall.
There's also a well known
truth, or truism, or something
like that, where if
you're in a maze,
and you put your
hand on one wall,
and you follow that
wall, then you'll
find the end of the maze.
So let's try to
watch that at work.
Actually, let's
make the speed 0.05.
So here we've got a bug,
and he's walking along.
The yellow represents
his left hand.
No, the yellow is
his right hand,
and he's following
the left wall.
So you can see he's going
to round to the left.
He's really not finding
the fastest path
from the bottom left
to the upper right.
But the point is,
he'll get there.
So there you go.
He found his way there.
Let's show that
again a bit slower.
So the goal here is when you
program a bug pathing system,
it's that the guy
has to remember
what direction he
has been going.
Because if he is just
in a position, just
any given position-- so
I'll pause it at some point,
say here.
So maybe he's here.
How is he going to know whether
he was going down or up?
That's the way that he
remembers his current state is
the direction.
Now, that's like a
big thing about bug
is that it doesn't
need any memory at all.
Its memory is sort of encoded in
its position and its direction.
And that's all it needs.
Whereas other forms
of pathing, you've
got to store these lists,
and how long they are,
and where they go, and which
lists are their parent lists
or parent nodes.
But bug is very simple.
Again, it's not really that
fantastic at getting you
where you need to go.
And you might also
ask the question,
what do you do when
you're not in a maze?
So let's go ahead and
answer that question
of what you do when
you're not in a maze.
And we can go over the details
of how to implement bug
if we have time at the end.
But you can look
all that stuff up.
So just in brief summary, we've
looked at depth first search,
breadth first search,
and bug pathing.
I'll talk more about
the details of each one,
but I like to just sort
of go through once,
and go through again
with more detail.
So let's change it to
an alternative maze.
This isn't what you're going
to have for battle code.
That would be terrible.
Mazes are not that exciting
in terms of video games.
Here is an example
of the kind of map
you'd have for battle code.
And what depth first
search is trying
to do to locate
the shortest path.
So first it's going deep.
It's going to keep going on its
path until it finds the end.
Now, there are ways of making
depth first search where
it won't do what it's doing
now, which is kind of silly.
What is it doing?
Filling space with this line.
And all these
possible combinations
of filling space with this line.
It's just wasting our time here.
It wants to go from
there to there.
What's it doing over here?
So that's an example.
We're going to make this
run as fast as it can run.
So let's pause the
evaluation and run it again.
As so you can see
now it's faster,
but it's still trying a
whole bunch of combinations
that just don't make any sense.
Here it goes along the left.
Here it goes along this side.
It's going to try verticals.
OK, now it's going
try all these.
OK.
Sweep, sweep, sweep,
sweep, sweep, sweep.
Now, let's hope, for
God's sake, don't
try-- oh god, it tried there.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Well, OK.
Now that it's tried
this area, let's hope
it doesn't go keep trying
these different things.
Like up here, let's hope
it doesn't go back there.
That'd been such
a waste of time.
So here it's going--
oh, what is this?
It's going--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: It's looping
around and spinning.
And now, it's-- oh, finally.
Man.
I'm going to fire that guy.
Let's see if breadth first
search can do any better.
Let's keep the delay at
0.1 and see what happens.
Oh, let's see.
It's searching the
nearby paths rather
than going down one that's deep.
I see.
Doesn't seem to be crossing
over old ground too much.
So if it's located
this point, it's
not going to try 10 different
ways of getting to this point.
One of the features of
breadth first search
is that if the
distance between nodes
is uniform, like every
square is the same distance
from every other square, then
as soon as you find the end,
you've found the shortest
path to get to the end.
So what we're going to
see is that it's not
going to keep looking
after it finds this tile.
It's just going to stop.
Bing.
OK.
And it's all done once
it looked at that depth.
Wow, that was pretty convenient.
Let's see how bug
does on the same map.
Now, this is just
showing the last result.
Let's see what result bug gets.
It's not going to
look like this.
So there it is.
It moved along and
followed this wall.
And then it stopped
bugging along the wall,
and then it followed this wall.
And now it's bugging
along that way.
Are we in a loop?
Nope.
No, we're not in a loop.
It's following along this way.
And bing.
It got to the result.
Pretty exciting.
Let's show that one
or two more times
to explain what's going on
when it's trying to do this.
As soon as it hits
a wall, bug has
to decide if it's going
to go left or right.
Later on I'm going
to talk about why
that can end up
being a huge problem.
You'll see it left the
yellow ball behind.
I only update the position
of the yellow ball
when I'm in bug mode.
So the point of bugging
in an open terrain
is that you have to be
able to leave the bugging.
You have to be able to
stop bugging at one point
and start just branching off.
Or else, for example, if
the goal were somewhere away
from a wall, you'd
never get to it.
Generally, a criteria for
leaving the bugging condition
is if you are closer
to the goal than you
were when you started bugging.
I see a question.
AUDIENCE: Why at the
very end, and also
before it turns on the second
wall, does it turn inward?
PROFESSOR: This one here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right now, when the
bug is not connected to a wall,
I have it going in the direction
that is toward the goal.
So here, this is like
the worst possible map,
because just when it wanted
to go toward the goal,
it hit another wall.
So that's why it turned inward.
And that's also
why it turns inward
over here and over there.
So that's a very good question.
So let's watch it again.
And what I want to
point out as well
is that the yellow is
places it wants to turn.
So here it wants to
make a right turn.
And here it leaves
bugging because it
was closer to the
destination here than it
was when it was
farther back over here.
So once again, it's moving
along, and it'll go around
and it'll find the answer.
So it's not very good
looking, but if your obstacles
don't connect with
the edge of the wall,
it find you sometimes
the same result
that you would get otherwise.
So I'm going to open
up something like Word,
and I'm going to
make some notes.
Because I can type faster
than I can write on the board,
and that makes a lot of sense.
Let's talk about metrics
of success in pathing.
There's the time to arrive.
You want to have a narrow
distribution of times
to arrive if you were
pathing a group of units.
Like if you're trying
to get to the other side
and you really
want them arriving
in a conga line,
that's potentially
going to get them
killed one by one.
You sometimes want to
explore the map as well.
And there are ways of
manually working out
some of these things.
What's the best path to
explore the map, and so on.
But these are just
things to keep in mind.
And let's look at
sort of a comparison
between bug a and depth first
and breadth first search.
So the bug system is
computationally fast.
But at the same time, you've
got your own trade off
between byte codes
and compute time.
It uses the unit turn, and
you can do that in two ways
with battle code.
You can do it with
Direction.rotateRight,
which will rotate that
direction 45 degrees.
Or you can do it by using, as
we did in the example yesterday,
Direction.values, which gets you
eight direction values starting
with north and going all
the way around to northwest.
And then you can
increment this index.
So if you're starting
it direction east,
that would be two, because
it's north, northeast, east.
So that would be two.
And then you can just add one
to rotate right, add another one
to rotate right
again, and so on.
It's pretty interesting that bug
can work blind in battle code.
Usually when you do
pathing, you want
to do something like
senseGameObjects
so that you could
say, all right,
I want to senseGameObjects
of robot.class.
I want to sense that
type of game object.
And I want all of
them, because I
want to make sure I don't
run into any of them.
In previous years,
you would have also
had to do senseTerrainTile.
Yeah, it would be something
like for a given map location,
you could sense--
yeah, it would be
like rc for robot controller
dot senseTerrainTile.
And it would be a given map
location and a or something.
And you'd put it, and
you'd say, is this equal
to
TerrainTile.terrainType.OFF_MAP,
or it would be VOID, or
it would be like OPEN,
or something like that.
And it was a huge bother.
So we got rid of void spaces.
So now you're basically
trying to say,
I need to use the
enemy mine locations.
And I believe there's a
senseEnemyMineLocations
or some method like that.
But you don't need those.
Because I said the bug is blind.
You could just get
by with canMove.
And that can be pretty nice.
If we're not making giant
mazes, you can probably just
get by using canMove.
If you can't move, then
rotate in some direction.
That may also end up being
cheaper computationally
than using these methods
for the same bugging.
I'm saying bugging
with canMove or bugging
with senseGameObjects.
For this kind of
stuff, I always find
it useful to go into the release
where I've got the folder where
I've installed battle code,
check my method costs.
I say, all right, let's
see here, canMove.
Here it is.
Costs me 25 byte codes.
How much does it cost
for me to senseRobotInfo?
Because I'm going
to get robots, I'm
going to have to sense
their info in order
to get their location.
That also costs me 25,
but that's after the costs
associated with sensing
all NearbyGameObjects,
which costs me 100, plus all
that other stuff I've got to do
to sort of set up a loop
with checking, and savings. .
No wait, that's a
different thing.
So yeah, we've got a
blind-- it's blind.
You should check your
leave-bugging criterion.
Can be something
like patience-- just
after a certain amount
of time, give up.
Distance-- are you closer
than you were before?
Direction-- how many times
have you turned left and right?
If you keep track of
that, then it can say,
all right, I've gone
around a barrier.
I know that cause of the
number of times I've turned.
So now I can be intelligent
about leaving that bugging.
So finally, with mass
pathing using bug,
you should consider
distinguishing
between off-map,
void, friend, and foe.
And here, void is more
realistically said
to be neutral mines.
I've said before
but I'll remind you
that you don't know
where enemy mines are
until you've stepped on them.
So that's sort of a difficulty.
Neutral mines are more
realistic to path around.
And you could consider
writing a rush player, which
locates the optimal way to
get from one base to another.
Because you know the bases.
You know where they are.
You know where the neutral
mines are to begin with.
So if you have some
of your robots,
for the headquarters
for example,
compute the optimal path between
your main base and the enemy
base, you could rush
there more quickly
than you would otherwise.
It's not really going
to work with enemy mines
though, because as I
said, you don't see them.
So you might want to distinguish
between these different types
of obstacle.
Because if a foe is in the way,
do you want to path around him,
or do you want to just
stop and start shooting?
I mean, of course,
in this battle code,
you don't have to
explicitly shoot.
And you move and you
shoot simultaneously.
It's worth mentioning here
that you shoot after you move.
That's something that
isn't entirely obvious.
You might say, OK,
it doesn't matter
whether you shoot
before or after.
That's just a little detail.
But it ends up being super
important, especially what
we're going to see later.
What we'll see is that, let's
say one robot of yours and one
robot of the enemy's are nearby.
If the enemy moves
toward you, then it
will immediately do damage.
Let's say that you subsequently
move away from the enemy
because you want to,
say, rejoin your group.
Well, you will move away
and then not do damage.
So the two of your robots will
move along in some direction,
and you'll take
damage every time,
and he won't take any
damage at any time.
It'll be no good.
Another thing is that if you
have neutral mines to path
around, well, those
aren't going anywhere so
you better path around them.
But if you have friends
to path around, maybe
you should just wait for
them to get out of the way.
Because presumably, they
are also pathing somewhere,
and so there's probably
just a traffic jam.
And does it make
more sense for you
to go running off in
another direction,
or to just have some patience
and wait there for the friend
to move?
At the same time, the thing
that I described the other day
surely applies
here, where you have
a wall of enemy units here.
And you've got me.
And you've got a
bunch of allies here.
And I want to be
here at my ice cream.
But I can't get there because
allies are in the way.
And I'm waiting
for them to move,
and they're waiting for
me to move, together
with all these other guys
that are all boxed up
behind this chunk of mines.
So yeah, you could realize
you'd get in some trouble.
This beautiful
diagram, by the way.
I save so much chalk that way.
I tell you.
Let's see.
So now we talked a little
bit about mass pathing.
I'd like to mention one
or two other aspects.
You could leave room for a bend.
And one way you
could do that is you
could say, all right, I
realize there's a corner here.
And the first guy that
goes around that way
will mark this as the waypoint.
Then other guys can go
straight to the waypoint.
Or if they're even
smarter, they'll
try to go around the waypoint.
So for example,
this guy could say,
he could mark all of these
positions as undesirable.
And they could radiate a force
outward so that every other
robot is being
repulsed by these x's.
And at that point,
you might start
to have the situation which
would be emergent behavior,
where your robots are starting
to intelligently sort of have
multiple lanes
around the obstacle,
rather than having just
one lane and getting
backed up behind one another.
So here they're
getting backed up.
And here they would
be sort of fanning out
in a sort of pretty way.
Yeah.
And you're going to see later
the effect of fanning out.
I mean, of course
you've seen it,
and you can imagine
how strong it
would be on the
outcome of a battle.
But that's going to be
really important when
we talk about the emergent
behavior of your army
when you take into account local
information about where people
are standing.
I hope you guys like the
analogy that I sent in my email.
I thought it was a little
bit contrived, but not too
terrible.
Not too-- OK, it
was pretty terrible.
OK.
So in mass pathing, also
consider your execute order.
As we've mentioned before,
if you have guys in a line,
and their robot IDs
are 1 and then 2
and then 3 and then 4-- yeah,
this is real pretty-- then
they can move left because
they'll execute in this order.
Oh, man.
It's like it's animated.
Ah, jeez.
But they can't
move to the right,
because this guy's in the way.
So number 1 will be like,
I don't know where to go.
I'm going to go there.
Number 2 is like, uh, I
can't go here or here.
Maybe I'll go up there.
And he gets lost.
His head's cut off.
AUDIENCE: Can 2 move diagonally?
PROFESSOR: Yes, 2
can move down here.
There is diagonal
directional movement.
Yeah.
And 3 could move down there.
And then I guess
4 could move here,
because he doesn't know
that the others-- it'd be
kind of cool if they did that.
And then they would
just like shimmy along.
It'd be like an inch worm.
That'd be pretty cool.
Oh, gosh.
Paint, don't do this to me.
There, that's much better.
So they could do
this, but 4 would
have to be pretty darn smart.
It's more likely that by now
these guys are inch-worming
along, and 4 is over there.
And eventually, 3 gets
sort of spread out.
And I don't know,
1 just goes and he
gets tired of the
whole deal because he's
been looking at 2's
behind the whole game.
So yeah, you definitely want
to keep in mind the execution
order.
And when I say keep
in mind, I mean
you could actually do sort
of like a bubble sort, where
if your ID is different from
the guy who's behind you,
you could switch places with
him and try to get behind him.
Because you can use the function
my robot controller dot getID,
and you'll have your ID.
Remember when we
did robot, and we
said, all allied robots,
or something, equals
rc.senseNearbyGameObjects,
the most helpful function
name in the world, and
we said robot.class?
You could say,
all right, all I'm
interested in is
the guy behind me.
Please give me the
ally guy behind me.
Well, you don't need to get
all the nearby game objects.
You could say, all right, I want
the one who is adjacent to me.
So he's within a
distance of one,
or say two if you want
to include diagonals.
And then I also want to make
sure that he's on my team.
So I do rc.getTeam.
So now immediately, I've got
a nice list of allied robots
that are nearby.
If I want to get
their ID numbers,
it's as simple as
rc.senseRobotInfo.
And I sense one of their info's.
This is aRobot, which I
can pull out of the list
by doing something simple
like I'll locate the closest
one in the ordinary way
that you would expect.
So now I've got the robot
info, and robot info
includes-- Actually,
I think you might even
be able to get ID from robot.
Where would I go to check?
I would just simply go
to the documentation
in the release,
all classes-frame.
I would see robot
info, just try to see.
Or maybe let's see if the robot
has-- oh, robot has getID.
Look at that.
So I don't even have
to senseRobotInfo.
I can just go straight.
So here I can just
say, ah, I'm just
going to aRobot.get--
what was it?
Get ID?
I think it was
either get ID, or ID.
And now I'll have that ID, and
I can compare it to my own,
and so on, as I said.
So this is all about bugging and
mass pathing in a simple way.
If you want to do it
smarter, you can use a*,
which is a breadth first search.
You can look up all Wikipedia.
And it's making a list
of where you can go.
That's as simple as it is.
You're making lists, and
you're keeping that list pruned
down so that it hasn't got
all these extra places for you
to look at.
So it's shorter to
get to your goal.
And what it can also do
is incorporate heuristics.
We'll be talking a little
bit about heuristics today,
where we're saying it's a fancy
word that, to the extent I
understand it, it just means
that the distance between one
square and another is
not necessarily one.
Or the goodness of being
in one square or another
is not necessarily the same.
So maybe you want a path
from point A to point B,
but you don't want to cross
a particular obstacle.
I saw once that somebody
did a giant paper.
I think they did a Ph.D. Thesis
on the traveling salesman
problem.
And they had solved the
traveling salesman problem
under the condition that they
were traveling in the United
States, and they did not want
to cross the Mississippi River.
That's so beyond--
why would you--
I love crossing the
Mississippi River.
But anyway, he didn't
want to, so he did that.
And I think he went ahead and
got-- now that I remember it,
it was actually a high
school science fair.
Ph.D., science fair, same thing.
So you can incorporate
these heuristics,
and it's just a
way of saying, here
I've got this list of
locations that I'm going to.
And I'm just going to associate
goodness or badness with them.
And at the end, instead
of saying distance,
I'll just say
goodness or badness.
It's as simple as that.
And that's how those things
end up getting done, and so on.
There's also d* and a whole
plethora of other things.
This is like start
from the destination
and go to the start.
There's various
reasons to do this.
There's tangent bug, where
you're saying, all right,
I recognize a certain
pattern to a* and d*.
If I start at this location
and I end here at e,
and the obstacles sort
of look like this,
well, the only
reasonable places for me
to go in this open
continuous terrain
is tangents between
the two things.
So I can draw a tangent there.
I can draw a tangent there.
From my starting position,
I draw a tangent to there.
You see these tangents?
They're right angles.
It's beautiful.
There's one here.
OK, that's a right angle.
This guy's got a tangent here,
and he's got another one there.
There's some arbitrary
dumb ones that never apply,
such as this one.
Or like this one.
Well, in any case,
there are ways
of pruning it so that you've
got just the right tangents.
And then you've really only
got like six paths to look.
You can go here, and then
there, and then there.
Or you can go here, and then
you can go from-- ah, yeah.
There's one.
You can go here
from there to there.
And then that's like a
really dumb way to go there.
So it's really easy once
you have tangent bug.
And there's a way to
generalize that so that it's
not just vector
geometry in open space,
but is down to the level
where you're like, OK,
these are individuals squares.
I zoomed in to indicate--
that was really smart.
It worked really well.
I was happy with it.
So there's tangent bug,
which you can use there.
And you could consider having--
in tangent bug especially,
you could imagine that a
headquarters could help out.
Where you have these things
that you need to get around.
Oh my goodness.
Anyway.
You want to get around
them so that you
could have the
headquarters indicate
what is the tangent spot.
And he doesn't have to
tell you all the places.
They're just like waypoints
to go to on your way
to the destination.
And it could work pretty well.
It could.
So keep in mind.
There are some
undesirable behaviors
to watch out for when you
do something like this.
Sometimes allied units that
bug in the opposite direction,
that makes a lot of sense if
you have a little obstacle
to get around.
But if the obstacle is
big, sometimes your robots
will come at one another
from opposite directions
when pathing.
So you'll have--
here is the obstacle,
and Robot a hits the obstacle
and starts going this way.
Robot b hits the obstacle
Robot b is here and a
tries to go around him.
b keeps going this
way, and a now
is like, I don't
know where I am.
I'm just going to
spin around in midair.
Because I thought I was bugging,
but then the wall changed.
I know that there's like a
million movies about how people
are in mazes, and then like
the big kicker is supposed
to be that the maze
is shifting over time.
Well, by now we're used to it,
and it's boring in a movie.
But when it happens in battle
code, it hits close to home.
Another undesirable
behavior could
be that you bug
around the whole map.
And one thing you can try to
do sense if the terrain is off
map.
Again, that would be
TerrainTile.TerrainType=TerrainType.offMap.
And you could check that, but
sometimes there'll be like,
maybe we'll put
neutral mine's all
the way around the
edge of the map.
And then you won't
really know if you're
bugging around the
edge of the map
because it'll just look
like neutral mines.
So there is another
thing to worry about it.
You could turn around
a transient obstacle,
like an ally, as we
mentioned before.
There's insufficient
information for a lot of things.
Like maybe you've got
the perfect a* algorithm
that's going to find everything.
That's the best
technical term for it.
And you're going
to find everything,
but you don't have
that much information.
Like you don't know where
the enemy mines are.
You don't know where
the enemy robots
are until you get close to them.
And so that I think that's
fairly well explained.
We've got everything laid out
on the table here and there.
I would mention that here's
another use for radio, is not
every robot can tell that
another robot is stuck.
So you might consider
radioing information
about robots that are stuck so
that the other robots, allied
of course, behind them
can get out of the way.
And you can make this
playful in your own way
by coming up with
your own comments
on what-- anyway, that
made a lot of sense.
So they can get out of the way.
So let's consider
the following case.
You have this radio system which
consists of these integers.
And you need to be able to
post map locations to integers.
How are you going to do that?
Well, I've got a
good idea for you
if you haven't
thought of it already.
An integer in Java can go from
something like minus 2 billion
to 2 billion.
So here we're radioing integers.
And it has to be an integer.
Well, I know a certain
thing about 2 billion.
2 billion has this many numbers
in it-- 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3, 1, 2,
3-- that's a billion.
Yeah, I got it.
I think that's 2 billion.
I think it has 2 billion
because it's 2 the 32.
Yeah, something like that.
Well, I know what
this can contain.
All I have to do, since
a map location starts--
it has x and y values
starting at 0, 0
and going to, at most, 100, 100.
And something tells me that
the final maps we give out
won't be that big.
But maybe they will.
I don't know.
They might be.
Well, look at that.
0 and 100 only take up three of
these positions in the number.
I mean, you could
do it in binary
and encode the information
even more efficiently.
But this will do just fine.
So here's a thought.
Put the round number
in the first three,
put to the x-coordinate
in the second three,
and put the y-coordinate
in the third three.
And now you can tell when
you look at a single integer
if it is up to date.
So here, we'll have 2,
roundNum, xval, yval.
And all you would do for
that is you would say,
my integer equals round-- it
would be-- let's be explicit.
Clock.getRoundNum()*1000000+xval--
it'll be my map location,
which I'll call m.x*1000+m.y*1.
There you go.
And that would encode
everything into my integer.
And then I could
make another function
that sort of unpacks
things into a map location.
Oh my goodness.
What would that look like?
Well, it would be something
like public static,
and it returns a map
location, because that
would be really useful.
Public static MapLocation,
we'll say intToMapLocation.
Yes.
That will be really useful.
And it takes an
integer, myInteger.
Yes.
I'm coding in Microsoft Word.
I wonder if everybody
has done that.
And if you're going to tell me
it's Open Office, that's true.
That's true.
I acknowledge that.
Let's see here.
So let's get the
other values on out.
Let's say that our x val, which
is going to be an integer,
equals myInteger at-- ooh,
what am I going to do here?
I'm going to say, I'm going
to take modulo 1 billion.
Is that going to do it?
I'm going to put spaces
in so that I can see it.
But I think if you
actually put spaces in,
it isn't going to work.
Yes.
So is that my x val?
No, that's my y val.
So I am going to do
this in this order
because it'll make it easy.
int xval=myInteger%1-- you
guys got to pay attention.
This is the 1 billion, isn't it?
Yeah, I've got to
make it this way.
Actually, I think they
might be identical.
Anyway, if I do it-- yeah.
Uh, no.
This has to be billion.
Sorry, that has to be a billion.
Because if I do
modulo a billion,
then any numbers that
are over here sort of
roll off from the 2 billion.
Yeah, that'll be fine.
And I'll just subtract from
the millions category--
would that be 1,000?
It'll be a million.
And I'll subtract
off the y value.
And now I have an x val.
And finally-- I mean, maybe
the first thing I should do
is I should check to see if
my very first number, like
if these very first
three numbers,
I should check to see
if those are decent.
I here some whispers,
but I'm sure that they're
talking about how amazing
this is going to end up being.
We'll make a new map
location by saying,
the output map location-- well,
I'll just call it outputLoc--
MapLocation outputLoc equals--
now this is a constructor--
new MapLocation-- this is the
same thing we did yesterday--
(xval,yval).
And I could have a
check in here that
verifies that it was set
at the previous roundNum,
so that it's not out of date.
That'd be really useful.
So that's a pretty useful
thing to have right there.
That's just one of
many byte code tricks.
So this is going to be packing
a map location into an integer.
What's another one?
Let's consider that you have
a whole stockpile of energy
that your robots are using.
But early on in the game, you're
wasting a lot of that energy
because it's just
decaying in your inbox.
It's just sort of
floating around,
and then it's going down.
So why don't you
consider spend byte codes
when the number of
allied bots is low?
Or equivalently, when there's
a lot of rc.getTeamPower.
Question.
AUDIENCE: For the
20% loss every round,
is that your total
stockpile of power,
or is it the total increase?
PROFESSOR: It will be
the total stockpile.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
You'll lose it.
So that's-- what's
the common saying?
It's use it or lose it.
Yeah.
So if you're using
it, you don't lose it.
I guess that was not
necessary to explain.
I made a program here that
may be useful on this effect.
I call it stockpiling.
And I made it in
Mathematica just
because it's nice and visual.
So here's an example of
stockpiling resources.
Let's go ahead and we'll
simulate 400 rounds.
We'll simulate the case where
the decay multiplier is 0.8.
And we'll start with zero
bots, using zero byte codes.
So you can see
here, this is what
you should expect your
number of bots to be.
You're building them
constantly, and you
finish building them
around turn 300.
And you hit a
maximum of 40 bots.
If you're using
more like-- let's
do a little bit more realistic--
you're using 2,000 byte codes,
well now, you're
maxing out at 34 bots.
And you can see here that
you quickly decay upward
to your maximum
near 200, and then
you only go down bit by bit
as you build more robots.
You may, for example,
have-- I mean,
we can look at
more examples here.
And I'll probably talk about
this more on a strategy
lecture, but let's say that
you got the fusion upgrade, so
that the decay multiplier
went from 0.8 to 0.99.
So now we've got 0.99 there.
Well, now you can see that
you got up to 44 robots
because the decay
was much slower.
So you got up to a
really big number
as you were massing
up these robots.
And so for about
70 rounds, you were
able to maintain an increase
of four robots over the enemy.
Not a huge benefit,
if you ask me.
Now, if you
stockpile for longer,
let's see what effect
that would have.
I guess this is a
bit of a tangent,
but we just did tangent
bug, so it's relevant.
Ba-dum!
Let's see here.
So where's the-- oh, yeah.
Number of rounds.
Round is greater than.
So we're only going to start
building robots at round,
say 200.
Now we can't really
see what's going on.
Let's increase the number
of rounds in the simulation
to 1,000.
So now we can see here
that we are maintaining--
we're having five extra
robots for slightly longer.
It's not that great.
It's just not that great.
Let's wait a little
bit longer before we
start building so we
can try to stockpile.
OK.
We've stockpiled as
much as possible.
We've still only got
five extra robots.
Oh, actually it's more
than five extra robots.
Let's go down to zero
so we can make sure.
Yeah, it's 12 extra
robots on top of 40,
so it's 12 over 40
times 100 is 30% more.
30% bonus, but you did it
at the price of stockpiling
for 500 turns.
And by then, you'll
certainly be dead.
That's a quick look
at stockpiling.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Is power used
for anything except for
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, power is
also used for capturing.
In my handy dandy unit
spec sheet-- gosh,
I did use that term.
Handy dandy.
In the spec sheet, which I put
over here on this place, which
you can get it on the website.
I could be going to the website.
I'm sure all of you
have been there by now.
And if you haven't,
then you're missing out.
This useful battle
code data sheet,
which updates from time to time,
indicates what takes power.
So if I just do Control-F
and the word power,
we can see here,
the headquarters
generates 40 power.
OK, we know that.
Soldiers upkeep to one
to two power per turn.
OK.
Attack power, that's irrelevant.
The generator
generates 10 power.
OK, I see that.
And then it should
also say somewhere
that you capture encampments at
a cost of 20, plus this number,
of units of power.
So if you own one
encampment and you
are capturing one encampment,
then the next encampment
you go to capture
will cost three times
the ordinary encampment
cost, which is right now 20.
So there you have it.
That's another use
for your power.
And it's certainly interesting
to consider that you might need
to call suicide on some of
your robots so that you'll get
enough money to buy some
of those encampments. .
Because that's a one time cost.
So you might suicide some
robots, build an encampment,
and then build those
robots back again.
Because it is not a
continuing upkeep.
Although I do believe
that encampments
count as robots to
the extent that they
do require upkeep themselves.
Let's go back and see how
much we have time for.
I'm sure everybody's
mouth is already
watering as much as mine
is about the chicken curry,
among other things.
I was over here putting
down byte code tricks,
and I got sort of sidetracked.
Let's talk about more
byte code tricks.
So let's think about how
it might be cheaper--
oh, my goodness-- to
broadcast an enemy's location
than to sense it.
Let's answer that question.
The method cost for
read broadcast is one.
And for making a
broadcast is also one.
Now, that's pretty
small compared
to sensing an enemy
location, where,
let's see, sensing
an enemy location.
Sensing an object is 25.
Sensing a bunch of
game objects is 100.
I mean, 1 is less
than 25 oftentimes.
So let's check if there any
other costs associated with it
by going into the specs
here under constant values.
So here in the Java
Docs, we can see
that there is also a
broadcast read cost.
So that also answers
this gentleman's question
that there's also
another cost in power.
This read cost is a power cost
for reading and broadcasting.
So this is going
to use 0.05 power.
It's relatively small compared
to your one upkeep [INAUDIBLE]
positions.
Well, then all of a sudden-- or
read 20 positions would be 0.2,
and that would be equivalent
to using 2,000 byte code.
So that starts to
say that that's
a pretty high cost for
reading in terms of byte code.
Which suggests that if you
want to send things on messages
and be byte code efficient, that
it makes the most sense to send
the results of a
large computation
rather than the base data
on which that computation is
performed.
Let's see here.
It's already 5:49, and
I haven't showed you
as many awesome matches
as I was expecting to.
I'll blast through a few
more byte code tricks
and then we'll get right there.
Make sure to check the byte
code cost of your functions.
I find it very helpful
to put in my code
a little block comment that
says what the byte code cost is.
And I'll put it right
next to the function,
so I can say, all right, that's
the price of that function.
And how many times can I use it?
Do I want to use it?
Is it worthwhile?
Am I improving it?
One way to do it is
to run the match with
and without that function
installed on your robot,
and just do the math yourself.
But another way is very simple.
You can just use
Clock.getBytecodes,
or something like that.
There's a function there.
And you can just do it before
and after a certain operation
and then check it out.
You should also try computing
only relevant directions.
Later on I'm going to show
you a little example of how
you can write code where a robot
is doing something in two ways,
and it's trying to find
out who's adjacent.
So it's like, all right,
I can move forward
and that would put me
next to this many enemies
and this many allies.
I could move to the
left and it would
be this many enemies
and this many allies.
You kind of want to be next to
a lot of allies and just one
enemy so you can gang up on him.
That was the whole idea of being
intelligent about your stance
and where you are.
Because you want
gang up on the enemy.
And that's a very
local decision when
it comes right down
to it sometimes.
But if you can't move
in a certain direction,
don't compute anything
about that direction
because you're not
going there anyway.
That's a thought.
I mean, of course, you may
compute it anyway, and then
try to move in that direction,
and move in the next closest.
But you could consider that.
And I'll show a little bit.
So you could consider spending
things only when it's low.
Cheaper to broadcast the
enemy using that, and so on.
I have another useful thing
when we're looking at pathing.
And I'll show it
by running a match.
I'll run the match
of Cold War, which
is my player, versus Hard Bot.
I have the Cold War
player, does something
that's similar to the
realistic Cold War.
But I'll do it on
slightly smaller maps
so you can see what's going on.
Let's see here.
Let's go on tiny.
So I made these maps
that are free of mines
just so I don't have
to worry about it.
So here we've got
Cold War in blue.
And his goal is
to nuke the enemy.
And what he does is he
paths around over here
around the med bay to
defend against the enemy.
And the enemy will be just
building these shields
and then attacking.
And they attack my med
bays, but they get nowhere.
I don't think I eve
lose a single guy.
So the Cold War
is going to finish
massing up a bunch of troops.
And when he's done, he's going
to build a nuclear missile.
There you can see the
projects going on.
Hello, and thank you.
Yeah.
And so he's building
along the nuclear missile.
And when he's done, it will
be curtains for the other guy.
Curtains, as it were.
We will bury them.
But you might ask,
I can't really
tell if these guys can
see those guys or what.
You can push the letter
A, which gives you
site range and attack range.
So that's a pretty useful
thing to have there.
So that's A in
the client viewer.
There's also another
list of commands,
like B will turn off
the broadcast range.
Let's look at some more options.
I would have liked
to go into a way
to store-- here's
another byte code trick.
Store the locations of other
units in an integer array,
so that instead of having to
loop through all enemy bots
and check if they're
adjacent, for example,
you can just store their
locations into an array
so that you know where they are.
Then you can just
index into that array.
And you say, all right,
this is where they are.
So you're indexing into
a two dimensional array.
And I can talk to you
about how to set those up
at another time,
but the result is
that you can perform
significantly better
than you otherwise would.
So here, Player 3 kind of works.
I'm going to show it where doing
this calculation, where you
find the number of adjacent
units can be pretty helpful.
So here's what I'm showing.
On the upper left and the
bottom right are the same robot.
But what I've done is I've
done, if your team is A,
then run the code this way.
If your team is B, then
run the code the other way.
And this is demonstration.
So let's back up just a bit.
I'll zoom in as
much as possible,
but that's as good
as it's going to get.
So let's go until
they're touching.
So this guy is computing
adjacent robots,
and he's printing out the
number of adjacent robots
that are allied.
In fact, I think
this might be-- yeah,
this is the number of allies.
Starting with north
and going around .
And this guy is printing
out different numbers
that are heuristics.
So for each of the
positions around him,
he is computing how
many allies there are
and how many enemies there are.
And he's going to try to
move in the direction that
has the most enemies.
So he'll either stay put if his
current location has the best
heuristic value, or he'll
go toward the best position.
Like if he's going to
try to flank the enemy,
or get to a position where
he'll gang up on the enemy.
And you can see here
that the red player
is able to make significant
advances against what
was previously Awesome Bot.
So you can see, I'll show
again, it's very hard to tell.
Because it's a subtle
thing that takes
place where it's trying
to do an optimization
at a very local scale.
So you're taking good decisions
on a robot by robot basis
and having them translate
into good decisions
on a global basis
for the whole team.
It was a bit of a
close race, though.
So let's consider
making global decisions.
Here's another
pathing idea where
you would be using the
local data from each robot
to decide that you
might want to form
a concave around the enemy.
So let's do that example.
And then I'll end with
one final example.
So this one is a concave.
I have them just build up
robots until round 200,
so I'll skip until there.
And you'll see
that the blue team
is going to sort of back away.
Here I'm going forward.
He's backing away
from the enemy.
And then when the moment
is right, he comes in.
Boom.
He comes in and
surrounds the enemy.
And they started with
the same number of units,
and look at how
many he has left.
Look at the difference
that that makes.
So you should really consider
having your robots think
about what's close to them,
nearby, and path with respect
to that.
I know it's not exactly
a* or d* or whatever,
but it's something
that's worth doing.
At this point, the
other guy really
can't return from that problem.
I'm just going to
show you one more
example of how things
can get interesting.
I've changed the constant
values all around a little bit,
just to show how things would
look if both players were
the player that tries to
avoid the other player.
Now of course, when
you write your own,
you write it in your own way
and it will behave in that way.
So it won't necessarily
look like this.
And there are things about this
that are just downright stupid.
But you're going
to see it happen,
and I believe it will be as
fun for you is it was for me.
So here we're on round 200.
I wish I could slow this down,
so I'll just click forward.
You see they're both
avoiding one another.
And just there, the
whole enemy team
was backing away from one guy.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Why?
That guy was moving
toward the enemy
I think because he
doesn't see them.
They move first
and then he moved.
So he can't even see them.
He doesn't think
he's that close,
but they think they're close.
Because this guy is Robot 138,
and this guy is Robot 139.
Can you believe it?
They're that close.
Oh, my goodness.
So they're going to
run away from one guy.
Meanwhile, these guys
are running away,
but they're also sort
of edging that way.
Because they figure
that's where the enemies
are because it's the
enemy headquarters.
These guys are running away.
And there's sort
of self-segregating
into these separate packs.
I don't think a single
bloodshed has been spawned.
That was the right
way of putting it.
And they're like wrapping
around one another.
They're going to trade
sides of the map.
This is absolutely bonkers.
So you can see here that
the red is pretty much going
to abandon his own headquarters.
Blue is going to abandon his.
Because they just-- it
got smelly, tiresome.
They want something
new in their lives.
And when we continue on
to the end of the match,
it's just a question
of which one
is going to be able to
deal the damage sooner.
Like this guy is saving himself
on the basis of producing units
bit by bit.
He's like, oh, if I stop
building units for one second,
I am dead.
I am totally gone.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Keep building units.
Wait, no.
These guys are eating
up all the resources,
and these are dying because
of the end of the round.
That is, they don't
have enough power.
No, please don't
eat all my units.
Please don't eat my resources.
You guys should suicide.
Protect the headquarters.
You're doing it wrong.
I swear, you're doing it wrong.
No, no, no.
You've got it all, but
now we're killing his.
And we're doing a lot, but oh,
we've taken a lot of damage.
Ahh, and then it's over.
And so there you have it.
A little bit of exciting stuff
happening with direction.
Thank you for coming.
But let me say that
one of these dishes,
I believe it's the
redder looking one, yeah,
the one in the middle, chicken
vindaloo, this time is spicy.
All right?
So beware that one.
Don't take too much of it,
because these guys know
what they mean when
they say spicy.
Thank you very much.